je vais te présenter les jardins de la
dissidence de jeunes a terminé ce qui
est une
un passage en revue de toute la vie
américaine des années 50 de nos jours
surtout le monde de dissidence est un
peu d'insurgés new yorkaise c'est
vraiment centralisé sur un sur un
quartier propre de new york et dans le
queensland dans le nord-est et donc on
va passer en revue et la grand-mère qui
est qui a eu un passé de communistes
vraiment très active qui s'est fait
virer du parti communiste parce que elle
couchait avec un noir ensuite donc à sa
fille qui prend le relais qui vit les
années 70 comme new york a pu vivre aux
années 70 et son petit-fils donc on
arrive jusqu'à occuper wall street
et donc voilà donc on passe en revue
tous ces mouvements interculturel qui
ont pu avoir lieu
surtout new york et on apprend enfin tu
as découvert des choses sur la vie et
politiques de new york enfin des choses
que tu connaissais pas du tout donc oui
alors ouais c'est ça en fait tu
découvres amont que ces mouvements avait
il y avait du monde
enfin il y avait un vrai terreau propice
à tous cette révolte là et que c'était
plutôt bien organisé et que voilà qu'il
y avait une vraie vie' aussi artistique
alors cette vision un peu culturelle et
politique de la vie new yorkais c'est
toute cette contre-culture qui existait
aussi par ailleurs donc ouais on apprend
pas mal de choses en même s'il paraît un
peu épais comme ça vraiment ça passe
comme un souffle et c'est une histoire
très haletant qui nous emmène jusqu'à la
fin c'est une histoire des etats unis en
fait vu par une seule famille une épopée
voilà un roman choral qui vit pendant 50
ans fin qui passe en revue 50 ans de la
vie de la contre culture américaine
voilà l'ami prodigieuse est le nouveau
nom d'hélène afférentes qui sont les
deux premier tome d'une saga absolument
exceptionnel italienne une grande
fresque romanesque dans le naples alors
le premier commence à la fin des années
50 dans le naples 2e on est dans les
années 60 et on suit en fait tout un
parti très populaire à naples et
notamment deux jeunes filles deux amis
donc dans le premier roman
elle commence l oms septembre on les
suit sur une dizaine d'années puis donc
de 17 ans à 25 27 ans à peu près pour le
second pour l'instant donc lna et lina
très très différentes l'une de l'autre
très très lié très amis effectivement
mais ce qui a surtout de très
intéressant c'est qu'on suit tout le
quartier et notamment les autres amis
qu'il y a et c'est un quartier très
populaire populaire dans le bon sens du
terme et avec plein de petits métiers
artisanaux et moi ce que j'ai besoin de
trouver génial dans ce roman c'est qu'on
suit ces deux jeunes filles donc là pour
l'instant sur sur 15 20 ans à peu près
et comment réussir finalement à sortir
aussi de son milieu ce que c'est ça aux
fins qui m'a plu dans le roman c'est que
là pour le coup c'était un vrai roman
social ce qu'il faut les lire dans
l'ordre enfin si tu peux avoir lu l'ami
prodigieux oui il vaut mieux parce qu'en
plus ça se suivent vraiment dire que là
où ce terme on al'impression vraiment de
records de le suivre ou pas [__] agir là
où se terminait un événement qui se
termine dans le premier et le premier
est le premier événement est là est
vraiment ces derniers évènements qui se
terminait dans le premier tome donc
c'est une vraie addiction vraiment parce
que d'abord elles sont attachants tout
le quartier est vraiment attachant moi
je suis prête à mettre à l'italien pour
venir les deux autres puisqu'il est là
encore deux autres qui sont pas encore
traduits c'était fini je te parlais du
nouveau roman de martin winckler qui
s'appelle abraham et fils alors
on va suivre l'histoire d'un jeune père
qui arrive avec son fils donc le père
s'appelle abraham son fils appelle franz
et tous les 2 débarque dans un petit
village en beauce il a obtenu un poste
de médecin et donc on va on va découvrir
l'histoire de ce père et de ce petit
garçon visiblement ils viennent
d'algérie
mais petit garçon n'a jamais connu sa
mère il sait qu'il ya eu un accident
mais son père n'en parle jamais et lui
laisse pas lui poser trop de questions
donc voilà on va suivre l'histoire de ce
père et ce fils et à travers l'histoire
de la maison l'histoire du village et
les questions que le petit garçon se
pose et qu'il va poser à son père on va
aussi s'interroger sur l'histoire
française
on est à l'époque du général de gaulle
donc toutes les grandes histoires tous
les secrets cachés durant l'occupation
ressurgissent à cette époque là et voilà
c'est le petit garçon qui nous raconte
sa et la maison dans laquelle il habite
c'est vraiment un très très beau roman
il ya toujours cette histoire de
médecins comme martin winckler et
médecins voilà c'est très beau c'est un
médecin de campagne qui emmène son fils
dans son histoire
et toi ce qui t'as aimé c'est plutôt la
relation voilà entre le père et le film
ou du temps avec la maison qui la maison
semble donc être là mais sans prêtre est
un portrait présent ce qui est vraiment
très bon en fait c'est donc la relation
entre le père et fils mais surtout la
curiosité et la navy finale de ce petit
garçon qui osent se poser plein de
questions et qui obtient des réponses
soit par son père soit dans ses lectures
soit en interagissant avec la maison
donc on retrouve beaucoup de l'humanité
comme on a l'habitude de voir un peu
avec d'un clair net et assurer cette
perception très très fine centre romand
ans laurent je te présente son dernier
coup de coeur vraiment gros coup de
coeur
invisible sous la lumière c'est
l'histoire de hagena temps déjà avec un
prénom comme ça c'est très plus génial
c'est une vieille dame d'un peu plus de
cent ans qu'un jour un jeune homme et sa
soeur
vienne prendre dans ça va bien de
chercher dans sa maison de retraite
elle comprend pas très bien ce qui se
passe tout son temps donc elle n'a pas
toute sa tête évidemment ils
l'embarquent dans sa boîte dans la
voiture et puis elle voit bien que la
règle et frère et la soeur sont toujours
en train de se chamailler et elle repère
quand même que la jeune fille pratique
la course à pied et la revoilà qui qui
se souvient de qui elle étaye la jeune
fille qu'elle était la jeune femme
qu'elle était la femme qu'elle était et
elle qui a pratiqué normand énormément
la course à pied donc on né en 1920 à
peu près une dizaine d'années on est
dans la rue elle a été élevé dans une
ferme à connaître bhutto d'un milieu
plutôt modeste
elle va nous raconter avec sa fratrie
donc son père d'un premier mariage avait
déjà eu les enfants elle sa mère était
plutôt guérisseuse avec est un médecin
mais connaissait très bien les plantes
et elle savait guérir donc beaucoup de
gens venaient venait la voir où venaient
envoyé on l'envoyait justement courir
pour aller chercher le médecin pour
aller voir le bonheur est là à la fois
l'agilité d'une nadia comaneci les
jambes du marais josé pérec en fait
d'accord et effectivement elle va être
opéré à 15 18 ans par un entraîneur pour
justement la faire pratiquer un point
niveau la course à pied et notamment
pour qu'elle aille avec l'équipe
canadienne pour participer en 28 aux jo
d'amsterdam où pour la première fois des
femmes devant participer aux épreuves
d'athlétisme et l'aspect sportif pro
patrol pas sûr non pas du tout non
c'était trop beau un entraînement
technique non pas du tout le contraire
ça donne envie de courir sa face avant
se dit là leur aval à cette fin
mais non c'est pas du tout parce que
c'est plus vraiment c'est très
intériorisée c'est vraiment plus une
une belle chronique féminine de fratries
aussi beaucoup et puis il ya comprends
pas ce que font ces deux jeunes pourquoi
ils sont venus chercher cette vieille
dame qu'est ce qui à l'heure où on
comprend que la gamine pas la petite
jeanne elle est fascinée par cette
grande dame qui a pour la première fois
gagner des jo
mais il ya quand même autre chose
derrière et c'est celle qui la découvre
et qu'on va découvrir le moment
quasiment à la fin c'est ça qui est
celle d'entrée assez prenions voilà
c'est un super vendre très bien voilà